hello class of 2020 he's past couple of
months I like most of you have found
myself feeling nostalgic for all the
moments that have made my time at Yale
feels so special but as comforting as it
can be to reminisce we must also open
our hearts and minds to what lies ahead
and today we get to do both we own the
class date committee are very excited to
share with you the class history
slideshow a compilation of photos
submitted by all of you
commemorating our journeys as
undergraduates but before we start
cringing at pictures from Yale up I have
the honor of introducing Dean Marvin
Chun who will offer insight into our
individual and collective futures as the
unique class of 2020 class of 2020
congratulations I am so happy to be with
you today even by video and to celebrate
with you graduating is a great
accomplishment one of the most important
ones of your life and now that this
moment has finally come
I am honored to recognize it with you I
also recognize all the work that you
have done to get you here much of it
with the support of your family and
friends today is your day and it is
theirs too over the past week together
with you I've enjoyed watching the
series of class day videos tomorrow
there will be a toast to the Yale class
of 2020 like what many of you have
celebrated in your residential colleges
on Sunday I'm excited for our class day
speaker dr. Jean Bennett a
world-renowned scientist and alumna also
this Sunday prizes will be announced on
the Yale 2020 website I am grateful to
the class day committee and to the
speakers who all contributed to this
class week series of videos and I'm most
appreciative to you especially now
during senior week I miss seeing you on
campus and I can't wait to welcome you
back to campus in due time we've already
started planning all the parties and
ceremonies that we will host for you and
your families so until we meet in person
please stay safe and well again class of
2020 congratulations Thank You Dean Chun
for your encouraging words and now let's
take a moment to look back at some of
your favorite memories from the past few
years
please enjoy the class history slideshow
alright so first question how would you
describe yourself as a first-year
[Music]
I was too confident naive but
well-intentioned
I was really eager to see what a yell
hadn't stored for me for the next four
years but I had no idea just how much
that would be I attended a little
academically intense
I was definitely extremely caffeinated
probably at any given moment I was
energetic enthusiastic
ready to just bag and I was always super
excited about everything but also a
little loss in computers constantly how
do I overcome sophomore slump I did it
really does anyone truly overcome the
sophomore slump
yeah hit that and just went down from
there just ready to feel like home when
Ellie oh joy
Lauren to last Sam Isaac and I committed
to having breakfast together every day
when I do be bought into the same
community I moved into my residence for
college and really got to know my suite
and I started feeling like a family way
through our huge Christmas party I was
on the phone with my mom she asked where
I was going and I said I was going home
but I didn't mean to Texas I was just
like walking from the grocery store back
to my apartment in New Haven the last
day of my first year when I had to think
about my roommate and I was like my
favorite first event freshman Olympics
on old campus but definitely my first
spring flag we didn't good spring fling
performers harvard-yale game Coverdale
for sure Harvard Yale Harvard Yale was
unbelievably life-changing we won after
having a really long losing streak and
no one thought it was going to happen it
was someone I've suspected and I'll
never forget the last few minutes of
that game ticking down when we realized
what was happening and everyone stormed
the field on the end
[Applause]
the community that has been most
impactful on me at Yale has double even
the Moores Community High City instincts
and seabrooke's you the acapella
community and more specifically mixed
company and the whiffs Pearson college
and a Yale ballroom dance team which I'm
a proud member
definitely dukes of Yale
hands down dukes my favorite memory is
on old campus when it turns spring and
everyone emerges from their dorms to
picnic that is the best like the first
sunny day on the old campus it was just
beautiful weather and Isaac's Kobe Thal
Sophia comfortable more mark Rosenberg
Emile Beckford and myself throughout
threw around a frisbee kind of for the
first time since freshman year my friend
Sophia is a freak oh she was doing
office hours on old campus where she's
just like what's outside and play guitar
and saying I lived in but also I love
being so close Harkness sour and hot
cake I loved hearing the bells ring
every morning I have a lot of memories
are just sitting outside on the dirty
benches for hours just talking to
whoever passed by just sitting down this
is someone did you don't know on a bench
introducing yourself and just kind of
that mingling of people from all
different colleges I made some friends
that lasted four years that way
something that surprised me about Yale
honestly is just how quickly the years
went by I can't believe like we're
graduating right now probably just how
much freedom
yo gives you you can really kind of do
whatever you want with your yellow
experience and the professor's the
faculty will be there to support you
through it anyone would help you if you
asked and I think that's something
that's really special honestly how nice
people are like I feel like that's
something that we people just say all
the time like people at Yale are so nice
but it's really true time is so short
when you're at Yale because there's so
much to do that's a balance but you know
I wouldn't have had it any other way
my favorite ice-cream spot on campus
Aerith you said arethusa ee Arethusa
Arethusa favorite ice-cream spot easily
agreed Arethusa butter pecan in a waffle
cone it was Ashley's for a long time but
now it's milk Kraft Ashley's gotta get
the frisbee
Ashley's has the best variety of flavors
but if you want richness and creaminess
go to here enthuses favorite yellow
dining dish gotta be the grilled cheese
the grilled cheese tenders chicken parm
if there are multigrain pancakes on the
menu I will wake up just for those
finish pancakes and they're so good I
gotta learn how to make them the
standouts for me are always in the
dessert department olive oil pear
cardamom cake I didn't even know olive
oil could be put in desserts but it is
the best thing I've ever eaten people
are sleeping on this dessert I already
made it like three times in quarantine
turned out terribly all three times and
I really wish that I could have just one
more slice favorite coffee shop either
JoJo's for the honey lemon ginger tea or
buck traders for studying definitely
blue state America the Acorn in silliman
college Atticus jojo's and okay
fuzzy coffee hands-down only
Willoughby's will abuse does it right
book trader cafe the egg and cheese
changed my life coffee would okay
because they have really good lemonade
and I like favorite New Haven restaurant
you even have a ton of fantastic
restaurants brew bombas RFS case of
China Baba or OAB Anaya's specifically
because of the midnight ramen noodle bar
mention Oodle bar any barcelona wins
I love York said if we're talking two
o'clock on a Friday then probably halal
guys always gets to spot me the best
things but for me is actually in my bed
if you are staying up late is the
Pearson dining hall music library
and st i'm the room with the fireplace
where you just put your feet up read a
book next to the fire window in the
acorn on the standing desks
[Music]
biggest mentors that yell oh my god
oh wow big question
JT professor Raymond Tracy from the good
life Center and [ __ ] from the yo
college office certainly is eager
mentors extra math mentors for sure
Reverend Jenny peek out here helping
people navigate queerness and
Christianity all the time the actual
like senior students in the student club
Yale launch they had founded their own
company and they were really big mentors
to me and not only in like the
entrepreneurship process but just
growing as a person to really believe
myself Danny again this man is
incredibly empowering and dedicated and
inspiring and Jeanine Tesori
just a mind-boggling
endless well of wisdom and depth
humanity now that I'm in quarantine one
thing I realized I took for granted are
the events and activities at Yale two
things the first one is just the beauty
of the campus itself
yeah the buildings and the second one is
all the people and how I could just bop
around from cognitive to common room and
hang out with everyone I I'm really
missing everyone right now the energy of
walking around and having people that
you can just run into on the street and
have a conversation with is something
that I really just a simple joy of
walking place to place and seeing people
you know you know passing by while you
walking across old campus across campus
or up Hill House just being able to run
into anyone's rooms and see what friends
are around and want to hang out what's
something you wish you would have done
before leaving campus I wish I walked a
cable house one last time I wish my band
could've played one more time I'm
missing her songwriter and I just
started performing live this year and we
thankfully got to perform a cafe night
and at the end of January and that was
very nice one last swing in the Berkeley
northward tire swing it's going to delay
Nia's pizza because I heard that it was
amazing and I had made plans to go after
spring break and I never made it there
but I will make it one day I wish
I would have had more a real chance to
say bye until my best friends I wish
that we could have given each other our
last hugs had those last meaningful
conversations in person I wish I would
have had one more late-night
conversation with my sweet yeah I think
we had a lot of those and then they
would last really long and they were so
fun and I wish we could've had one more
I wish I could just remember and say
goodbye to like one last normal day it
doesn't even have to be a perfect day
just like one last normal day
[Music]
I think the most important thing that
I've learned at Yale is just the variety
in the ways that people like live their
lives and then and how they've gotten to
where they are I've just learned about
so many different ways of life it's how
to deal with really honey believably
difficult times at least the ones I've
faced so far it's taught me grit how do
prioritize our relationships and how to
really be there for my friends how to
stop procrastinating I just need him a
lot better at doing things ahead of time
you just do your best don't compare
yourself to others and just take pride
in your own accomplishments I want to
say thank you to my sweet to all of
Pierce in college to the Yale ballroom
dance team for really giving me a home
at Yale thank you to CNN for being the
absolute best senior year roommate you
were there for me Milo's you celebrated
with me my highs I I'm so grateful to
you so thank you thank you to the
Whiffenpoofs for making me part of the
class of 2020 it's great thank you to
the class of 2019 in the class of 2020
for being my original and current
communities I yeah I would like to thank
you for pushing outside my comfort zone
and really challenging to think about
what is it that I am passionate about
thank you to Professor Jewess for taking
the time to help me understand so many
different things that I hadn't known
before about the humanities and really
just giving her all for every single
student she has thank you to Professor
Tracy who taught my writing for
television class for teaching my
favorite class that I've never taken at
Yale and making me realize as I went
through the semester that I would love
to end up in television at some point
thank you to all my friends for the
and memories that we made I miss you
guys all so much and thank you to Yale
for my bright college years we almost
made it to floor thank you to Yale for
every day
[Music]
[Music]
you